you know you got a classic with Kanye
West
exactly one of the uh more iconic
visuals of our of our last five years or
so exactly most most viewed video in the
first week
is that is that like ever ever you guys
have the big [ __ ] you know the big
shoulder pad joints what do you think
about what's going on with yay right now
hey man I don't have no say-so in that
how did that like initially happen you
guys working together
well
this was on my 18th birthday he had
called me
um Six Flags 18th birthday present Tanya
calls you yeah it was my 18th birthday I
was throwing this huge mansion party and
I just got this random phone call yeah
and it's yay he's like yo I got some
[ __ ] for you I'm like let's get it I was
shroomed out that day I was shrooming
balls nice
I was out of it and then
bro we just grabbed the studio equipment
it wasn't even though like you know how
like a big Studio big Studio it's not no
[ __ ] Mike knows Sony c100 we just
grab we literally had a 500 mic wow put
in a small room
lay down the verse send it back to him
that's just crazy and I was like same
night while you're shrooming hard well
I'm shrooming so you record that while
you're [ __ ] shroomed out yeah wow
that's [ __ ] crazy
Truman balls